you should just walk out of camp Oh
Odelle yeah he should just be like
alright see ya all right we ready
I know he can leave really no I mean
there's more there's gonna be more
consequences to it right because now
they'll have the power to basically be
like oh no he left camp and they'd be
able to put him like the NFI but then
the non football injury list or whatever
they'll put something like that but what
he didn't what he has to do is he stays
and then he just gotta hold it he has to
have a type hamstring so it's when you
go there and you can't run you don't
feel that Miami's tight I can't play
today he's gonna have to do that
alright so Lola and so you play on we're
gonna get two black Klansmen John David
Washington and and of course but you
play Ricky Jerret which is kind of a
diva wide receiver in ballers if you're
a receiver you're a diva
John David sorry I would say that you're
a self-aware diva you show you at a
history of diva but you go I don't want
to be that anymore like I feel like
that's your struggle the time incitive
yeah a weak way but he just feels
everything you know this guy who does
you do well it is therapeutic so like it
is kind of therapeutic to be able to
explore this guy and when he does crazy
stuff that he does so when you play a
wide receiver then do you look at Odell
Beckham and can you see the character
that he is well I mean I just was able
to collect a wealth of experiences of
all different positions of throughout
the years and just kind of combine it
you know to me it's about sharing the
experience with the people that don't
understand I'm sure the perspective of
the athlete what was your compilation I
thought you were a little Jarvis Landry
but that's only because you were in
Miami so I put that together but I saw
that maybe a little Antonio Brown in
there well I mean I was steeped in the
Steve Smith
Jerry Rice a lot of the greats but just
like Randall Cunningham he's the reason
I wanted to play football well I never
seen anybody that looked like me at that
position do what he did I feel like he
sort of revolutionized the position yeah
are you Eagles fan are you serious I
brought a best friend I'd brought it
best friends now we're besties I had a I
brought a Brian Dawkins shirt did you
watch the hall of fame no I missed it I
see some of these I've seen how you came
out though like so our man here actually
has the single game record at morehouse
242 rushing it's not broken when the
internet says it's still staying
internet never lies and career nearly
3,700 rushing yards Toth the rock dude
all right yeah well your dad I mean I
gotta ask you about him first of all
first of all thing is like that as
Denzel washing your love of football
growing up I mean was dad the type of
guy that had football on Sundays and we
were sitting there and that's that's how
it happened yeah that Pop's uncle my
uncle Rick on he lives in North Carolina
he loved the Green Bay Packers Packers
in the Celtics he was a big Larry Bird
fan right so yeah it was always sports
but football yes football Sunday and
what about dad whose dad squad to tell
he's a Dallas Cowboys I realized earlier
this morning that you two have
experienced opposite interactions your
entire lives yes
John David people have come up to him
his entire life and they go is your dad
really that cool and Chris your entire
life people have come to you go is your
dad really that core character yeah I
feel like you guys have had opposite
interaction well we definitely I'm sure
he could speak to this because his
father is in a whole nother stratosphere
of superstar than Phil Simms let's get
serious here okay
okay but yeah I did recognize that early
on that yeah I mean I was still son
that's I wasn't even Chris until I
started to like my everyday well yeah I
didn't look at it as pressure I almost
looked at as a chance to show off here
you cuz I knew I was good and I was like
oh these people want to come here and
you know see what phil simms sun-god I'm
gonna show him what I got it's exactly
there's seven 3-pointers later yeah you
you were able to embrace it as that's
where I was kind of going with it well I
I sort of used it as this sort of like
rebellious quest of independence you
know I mean and I was like like to your
point of I'll show you yeah you know my
father can't help me on the field in
fact hurt me they would be more
motivated to try to hurt exactly they
would copy they with me was a great a
great motivator I think it's what got me
over playing with broken ribs torn
meniscus you know clavicle a couple of
concussions so that motivation to be
like my own man right my mom was was
that was a part of that fueled yeah yeah
certainly you did you were under it to
freeze with the Rams you played with the
Rhine fire oh I loved it too mainly
because when I would play Madden there
would be the other team yes
I don't want to date ourselves but like
the worst thing I talk about even on
like the lower like the early 2000s the
worst thing would be when you'd
randomize the teams and they would get
packers and you get like the Frankfurt
whatever yeah so what was what was the
NFL Europe like I let's Clyde was it was
a great learning experience well
socially and as far as the game was
concerned they loved us out there yeah
clean family fun only like an inch or
two wider when you said socially
culture concert I get it but that's
where you had a lot of fun though
because I've heard that from a lot of
like hex players and stuff that you know
yep playing there was great getting that
experience but being able to live there
right they just say right dude I read
about this guy that what they they flew
him out to Italy and he was like the
only NFL player that went to Italy and
he was just a legend he's like why would
I leave like my family's in Italy we
always hear about NBA players going
abroad but that was I would like to see
you'd like to NFL expand again
internationally and get these
supplemental leads going over there and
where he's their awareness of the nature
of the game and the purity of it yeah
you can start that foundationally out
there I think yeah German fans they're
like organized chaos right like just
like soccer for their football right
they stand there was a section that
stood up the whole game and chanted in
unison it was great yeah tell you yeah
do you have any good Ryan fire stories
for we're like craziness like I can see
what's y'all and I don't even need it to
be the party one more like you know how
like there's a team and it's coming
together and it's like kind of haphazard
like what was it organized chaos yeah
yeah I mean we would meet we lived in
the hotels we met in the hotels that was
where the meetings were was at the
conference rooms over there so that was
our lives to hotels but we had a lot of
time off too they were like we got the
meetings done see you later see in town
so you know there was a lot of freedom
to get in trouble yeah that's amazing
what's not like the NFL no well yeah but
that's what you do you get the free time
and that's where the young players
always struggle because they're like man
in college I had to go to study study
hall and all that stuff money and more
time exactly which is a dangerous
combination when you're 23 and 24 years
old you all right I mean the course
sports was your love but you always kind
of kept like acting in the back of your
mind knowing I didn't realize that was
you and Malcolm X was a little boy I did
not realize that that's unbelievable
yeah no I like I said before to this
positive rebellion so that meant I had
to sort of bury my true passion and love
which was acting yeah I saw my father do
Shakespeare in the park when I was four
years old
and I love the thinning in the movie
glory I knew every line of every actors
in that movie that's what I wanted to do
but in his ascension in the business I
was starting to get more popular more
recognized and sort of this getting put
on this sort of pedestal when did it go
to the next level and your debt in your
life where you're like Philadelphia what
is it when does it go next level to
Spike Lee I mean Malcolm X sort of
changed all that change your life me
security yeah but even how I was getting
treated like I would so some of that
resentment and anxiety I got from
different treatment from other people I
sort of funnel that and used it as
gasoline or fuel I should say into
football but the whole time I was
bearing what I really wanted to look
really wanted to do but my parents are
like artists like my mom went to
Juilliard a classically trained pianist
taught lessons at 11 years old to us all
so they were all about processed right
art of it the craft arts and crafts of
it all you know and that's what I fell
in love with not the result I mean it
doesn't mean you're gonna be famous or
anything but that's not what we were
about yeah that's not what they were
about and and so that kind of that kind
of shifted when so this movie black
clansmen you were Ron Stallworth
the first black detective in the history
the Colorado Springs Police Department
who outwitted David Duke with only a
high school diploma you're reading this
character did you fall in love with it
right away
yeah tell us like the backdrop of the
story a little bit just for the people
listening everything I got a text I was
on location doing another film in
Cincinnati
shout out to Cincinnati to great food
and I got a text message from Spike Lee
like yo despite call me I don't talk to
Spike Lee but I got investigate like
just in case it is so I killed hello yo
John he called me John like my name is
John day by John so I got this black
black detective and call he talked like
real Oh Colorado Springs takes down the
plan the Klan
waste and I'm in my head I'm like that's
the elevator person like man this is
like they Chappelle write book so he
sends me the book I read it I call them
back like just like on cloud nine this
is crazy
what we doing he's like Betsy to summer
that's how I got the job and you know
just a story like this one it can only
be told by Spike Lee or Jordan Peele as
well as producing and it was just I
couldn't believe it and so like the book
is way more detailed in the movie but
but the fact that this happened in our
own backyard it's an incredible
incredible true story I mean I gotta ask
a few more like about spike I mean spike
I look at spike and they almost think
like okay well we talk about Bill
Belichick and all the great things he
does in the world of this ball and how
he goes along his process what was it
like what Spike Lee as the coach of a
movie is he like hyper critical is he
cool does he let you find your own way
what's his process all the above like
you'll catch some heat everybody
somebody would catch heat on set one day
yeah you but you got to get over it you
know you gotta you gotta you gotta have
thick skin because it's all in service
of the film it's about the team concept
never have I been on a set quite like
this where everybody wanted to be there
seemingly what seemed to be one wanted
to be there or service of film to the
best of their abilities and the freedom
I had I mean he trusted me this legend
right yeah trusted me with this material
meaning he didn't I didn't really get
any knows like you know we do blocking
stuff and positioning and camera stuff a
couple of adjustments he would he would
cut down what he didn't like but he told
me to trust your instincts John David
touch the instincts you got this it was
great so this legend yelling action and
cut trusted me with the information with
this with this project
I've never such a liberating experience
because it's not always like that on set
sometimes it got you in a box yeah so so
yeah and expound on that expound I make
up words you gotta watch out but no but
I guess like when you say freedom to I
mean okay so you got your lines to the
movie and he basically just says he
doesn't hold you to the letter of the
law of every line does he just let you
cut it I mean there was so much
ad-libbing going on well I think he's a
master at recognizing energy and
momentum these great coaches sometimes
when field doesn't call a timeout yeah
let them figure yeah you know like
that's that's you gotta have confidence
in your system and yourself and then the
people that you brought on the team
right so his confidence is in
oh I don't what I know I picked the
right guy Topher he's a right guy Adam
he's a right guy Laura's the right woman
so that's where the confidence is so he
let you do your thing now we had
discussions and if we go way left we'll
bring it back right but never I never
heard him once it can you try this way
can you be funnier can you be those
those generic notes sometimes we're very
frustrating as an artist this is because
of that word yes very ver generic yes so
but like in this case with this story -
I mean when he gave me that kind of
trust it just the confidence oh I'm just
soaring was just going through the roof
awesome so it was you know just a very
fluid experience expound does play
expound those by their express in a lot
of details okay so you go through and
what's interesting is I've now heard
your father speak numerous times about
his disdain for social media and it's
funny because you were talking before
about how they're artists and now I hear
you speaking about the craft and I think
it's very funny that a lot of people at
our society look past the craft and they
look at the celebration and they go I
want the celebration but they're not
they don't see the process and part of
the reason we love Bill Belichick and
and you know a lot of the great coaches
the NFL is it's all about the process
and then when the celebration happens
they go this is a result of that but a
lot of people just want to lift the
trophy or those worlds similar have you
been able to bring football into acting
yeah absolutely I mean preparation
sometimes superstition you know like
same clothes the same song you know if
you've had a great acting day you're
where they say but I'm definitely gonna
I'm definitely keep like I keep my
uncle's car wash bracelet on me with
criticism I'm sure that's what helped
right you must be great at well listen I
would run for 242 and a touchdown or two
touchdowns in as Denzel Sun ran for so I
you know that kind of criticism or that
kind of critiquing I'm just black
Klansmen you are on set you said that
Spike Lee gives everybody one one was
the day that he gave it to you
I think the I think it was a second it
was the fourth day okay but he did it in
and not away he would expect so it was
it was I was kind of nervous that day we
already been shooting a week but it was
like it was the most lines I've said
from the script that day so I was a
little nervous so I we do it a couple
times he walks over and he's not looking
at me he's like like if you're me I'm
spike he's like this so we're gonna
bring the camera this way you're gonna
walk over and say I love that and I
cracked up and I was off to the races
bed I was those though so that's my
version of like and it it to me cuz like
I like like man up a little bit like he
or he could tell again he just look it
was great dog in the Phil Jackson yes no
Jedi mind you yes it was great because
it's not about coming at Sheetz about
bringing the best out of right well she
knows how to knowing how to communicate
with your personnel some people do need
to just that kick in you know you got a
yeah others you need to you know talk to
him the way you talk to him today you
you I want to hear like yeah I want to
hear what more about the movie itself to
just if you want to know the concept
that basic concept just to hear it
because like I've seen a few commercials
here and there and I know the basic but
I'm here okay Ron never changed his
voice so if he was sitting here talking
to you that's how he was talking to the
Klansmen right which makes them even
more like how dare you be so civilized
yeah exactly I mean I talked about like
black people say all right like it's
there's a whole bunch of stuff in the
film that you'll have to see but just
diction and cadence like is dictated by
the white man yeah it's it's good
old-fashioned American hate yeah I mean
and how we see how organized it is in
the forms of these organizations of the
Ku Klux Klan and see how generational it
is we're seeing it right now well I was
he ties that all in and into the film as
well you know Klan has had resurgence is
they from Birth of a Nation which played
in the White House yeah then David Duke
putting this nice neighborly white man
who speaks
you know these racial slurs Virginia
incorporated in the
now he's not hitting you over the head
though with messages like master yes
it's package and delivery as one of an
entertainment capacity it's something
you can enjoy you're almost reluctant or
apprehensive to laugh like I don't even
know why I'm laughing at that
but it's you're laughing at how
ridiculous it is in these performances
that he's getting out of the actors and
the fact that the basement the backbone
the spine of this film is a true story
yeah we're standing our history here
right so it's it's such a unique feeling
one that I'm proud to be a part of i
watch a lot of films and I must say even
if I wasn't in it I'd be I'm going to
see this yeah that kind of finds out all
the inner workings of you like he was
monitoring that the Klan that was it
that was the mission it was a sting
operation so he he conducted he started
the operation over the phone and he just
started spitting these crazy racial
slurs out and hate was like oh yeah we
like you that's you speaking our
language is saying in this film I mean
with all the harsh language
it's a purposeful and you're seeing this
lexicon of hey mm you know it was sort
of how you know some people speak French
bilingual is a hate language and and you
it's really displayed in this film - Wow
and you saying again how generational it
is some of these trigger words are still
being used today and we're also seeing
like how people feel and talk at their
family barbecue you know at the local
bowling now sure is how people feel and
think in this country for years yep
that's what I was thinking you talk
about spike just letting people ad-lib
that's the only way you really get
natural speech you know cuz I think
natural performance yes I mean when you
tonight you got to do your prep work to
earn of course and but when you're in it
like some of the best stuff you can't
plan for I mean if I got a outside zone
to the right and there's 300-pound
linemen that's in the way I'm like I got
a cut I gotta come back and that might
be the touchdown I'm not gonna just run
into the guy right so a lot of times
again talking about what I got from
football got to be able to tackle yes
you got to be able to work with and just
feel it out and that environment must be
created by your coach that freedom to do
that Spike Lee
afforded us that freedom in such a major
way did you see any acting chops thus
far on ballers have any of the NFL
players impressed you with their
abilities
oh well yeah I mean you don't have to
get Jackson
she's talking about an elephant that he
bought yeah yeah I gotta go back there
was uh he talks about imminent I was
Adeline Pete Berg who directed the pilot
he did a Friday Night Lights on nothing
he was just like shouting us to talk
about your elephant you barb and Steve
was gone with the Steve Jackson was
going with he was right there with us it
was great yeah we could have hung with
Pete it's a good time yeah
does your dad call when you're in the
middle of the movie do you ever call ask
for hey Dad I got this scene blah blah
blah I mean I know I wasn't above that
as far as Annihilus playing or he might
call me and get Christopher Julius
Peppers is big make sure you step up in
the pocket he talked about working with
Spike and his experiences but I've been
listening to his stories for years
anyway even before this write and love
when he talks about you know sometimes
he says the same story and the kind of
alternate versions but yeah I asked my
mom too though because you remember what
I remembered is there when it you know
so yes so just getting that alright and
last one for me cuz I know you got a
life and you have better things to do
than the sims left go podcast good time
I am I am interested in this I want to
know what your what's your what's your
favorite movie of your dad's and then
what's the movie you believe he acted
best in which is like his best
performance and them what's your movie
that you got that was Phil sit with us
performance Super Bowl 21 he was 22 of
25 or 26 a virtuosity there's so many
good ones I know man crypts it's how you
use coaching me I was me sunshine you
didn't know that oh you're thinking yeah
in the submarine which I also saw as
well
was a lovely like sunshine - I would the
night before we played Oklahoma at Texas
we went to see that movie and the team
started going so yes I did get that you
were say it's alright messed up that
movie I saw crimson times as well yeah I
mean what he and gene Hackman that put
him in his place
it was like gene hit him like twice yeah
you still look like our count if I could
put up you could still look like a G
after you got stolen twice right and he
pulled that up but it was I loved he and
Tony Scott's chemistry and love fire was
amazing I was watching I watched it
every year I got Tony Scott had that run
with like Domino and man on fire where
it was just the cuts and the flashbacks
and the style of filmmaking is getting
used today yes time really and so I mean
he in spite combination of Malcolm X is
one month I know you know I mean this
month right now is Malcolm X but a month
ago was man on fire me before that was
Crimson Tide before that it was with
training day so yeah training day is
movie what is your favorite movie of all
time Sims my favorite movie of all time
is probably the Godfather one and two
okay cameras the same thing yeah yes
yeah that is that is what's up there
mine is Ace Ventura - and nature calls
like your lovin you ask someone no parks
and wanting does like a glove the thing
flips and it lands but he said he didn't
want that's what start my they know is
when you ask someone what's your
favorite movie I always feel like
they're trying to impress you and they
don't give the movie they want to watch
the most they give the one that's like
been also cortically acclaim they're
like oh I love
Dances with Wolves
like are you kidding me like that's maca
come on man so we do a thing during the
season where we have to bet on games and
I've beaten him now for four years in a
row even though he played as a
professional I'm a better gambler and
what happens is sometimes mascots come
up and we were doing the bills and he
just kept going to Tonka Tatanka never
seen it I was just like you ruined
everything they have a civilization and
they're not just like how did you watch
the Super Bowl
what was your setup so that whole I
watched it by myself because I was too
good for you I couldn't be with people
you know I was focused in the whole
playoff run I did I never watched the
first quarters so how did that happen
you just missed the first one like no
you know what because I was I was a
little nervous about of course and it
just and it worked best practice today
dee dee
he's tight in the upper body it's okay
it might be time again I say fools the
first three weeks of the year because
here's the reason why the reason that
you keep foals is so that we don't have
to rush back Carson Wentz Carson you're
at like 85 guess what we have Nick Foles
he'll be fine the first few weeks of the
year they're both they're both men of
God and they both really respect each
other I don't think there's gonna be any
issue and when Carson's ready bring them
in I think we have the rare opportunity
to give him a longer runway if he's a
hundred percent let him play but if
you're kind of not sure about it
that's why you have Nick Foles like I
think this is a benefit not a deterrent
all the TV shows are gonna say who do
you play pick one I say play both like I
just like given the history of this
league when has it ever worked a dual
quarterback in them no almost never
that's I don't I mean I know what he's
saying I guess yeah you know but they're
just you're you're if he is close to
playing once they almost have to play
might as well just try to trade once and
go there are easy games to do you know
any other coach might be like what Heep
is playing average but you know the fans
don't really know that because we won
and yet he's still gonna have to play
even if he's not 100% actually benefits
the franchise like they can blame like
we still wouldn't quite right right
right right they can play that angle
even if it's for mental pressure so
Super Bowl you watch by yourself watch
by myself I don't even eat this is
historic we could never get past that
hump so I'm just kidding like the Reggie
White days in the Fred Barnett yes I met
Randall Cunningham he gave me his glove
he told me I could be anything I want to
be I appreciate that Randall
cuz I'm doing that I'm doing it had a
Randall man I'm a huge Randall guy so
hey you had a random moment at the Pro
Bowl yeah Randall was my guy boy kept
every time my dad played him back in the
late 80s early 90s he turned the corner
and have a big runner where Carl banks
would knock him on the ground need stiff
on the ground and pop up so you dude
this stuff like you said to start the
interview where I go damn I've never
seen quarterbacks do this [ __ ] I've
never seen anybody outrun Lawrence
Taylor around you at the Pro Bowl so at
the Pro Bowl I was obsessive wasn't it
was a quarterback challenge oh and I was
obsessed with them and he was so nice
and cool as hell you're how old and I'm
11 and I was like damn Randle likes me
we're buddies and I just started
following him everywhere in the hotel
but you couldn't been better and that
was the year he got hurt and everyone
was like you got to change the way you
play and when we left the quarterback
challenge I got home yeah I was right
around that time he sent me all this
stuff of like all his like Randall I'll
be back running gear hats
t-shirts water bottles with Randle's a
male so you're blessed by Reynolds
pregame who's warming up your game with
my dad spell your dad's Denzel you win
that's awesome John David you're the man
do congratulations on anything check out
black cat plans maybe it is gonna be all
over every movie theater pretty much and
then also ballers it's now with the
third season for fourth season yeah
we're family yeah we're all under the
same umbrella that's right we just got
that Time Warner that we always were
before AT&T
[Music]